[Music]
the Westminster accounts a new way to
follow the money through our political
system giving you the chance to track
your MP and who gives to them yesterday
we revealed which MPS are the most from
second jobs and
calls for change the more transparency
the better today the men women and
businesses who put their money into
Westminster too long just part of the
punch and duty of our politics they're
paid by the union barriers and they're
and they're proud of it simple truth is
that they are the party for their tax
Dodgers not their taxpayers but the
reality of who gives who give our MPS is
far more complex than the game playing
suggests
a
jet
[Music]
tracing the network of donors to MPS in
Parliament has never been easy links
have long been obscured in a system that
was never designed to be properly
analyzed
now here's something you genuinely
haven't been able to do before you might
recognize these names they're the top
donors to political parties four big
unions who've given over 21 million
pounds to labor wealthy individuals Lord
sainsbury and JC Bamford who opened
their checkbooks for the lib Dems and
the conservative party but this is what
we've never been able to show you here
is who's been giving the most cash and
support to individual MPS over this
Parliament so since December 2019 again
some names you recognize two of the
biggest unions are the biggest donors
unite and GMB with some of the biggest
sums going to labor MPS on the left of
the party in fact over half of unite 600
000 pounds of donations to individuals
go to Just Three labor MPS Rebecca Long
Bailey Richard Bergen and Barry Gardner
but then this becomes a story about what
we don't know and to tell it we're going
to focus on two companies in this list
the third biggest donor to MPS in this
Parliament is a little known entity a
Hertfordshire business called npm
connect they give well over a quarter of
a million pounds to just three
well-known labor MPS Yvette Cooper Dan
Jarvis and Wes streeting
such a big donor so little information a
company but it's not clear what it does
or where it gets its money it has no
website its accounts say there are no
employees two directors are listed but
no public route to contact the company
itself
we just wanted to understand who was
behind the donations and why they gave
the money so we asked the MPS themselves
Shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper who
received a donation of 180 000 pounds
from the company her office gave us a
statement they said was not to be quoted
Shadow Health secretary Wes streeting
said everything was declared in the
proper way Dan Jarvis said all of his
donations support his work as an MP not
the answers to the questions that we
hoped for
so we travel to Hertfordshire to the
company's registered address
hello there I'm from Sky News um we're
trying to get in touch with people from
npm connect this is the address for npm
connect Peter Hearn or Simon Murphy did
you know whether I can speak to them or
how I can contact them
do you recognize the names I'm talking
about
you look confused
have you heard of npm connect accounting
yes have you heard of npm connect
you haven't heard of npm connect it's
it's registered address is here
have you heard of Peter Hearn
well Simon Murphy the two directors for
npm connect he's a registered hip yes
we're from Sky News we're trying to find
out more about npm connect
[Music]
but you said you don't you haven't heard
of npn connect
[Music]
but why not we're just trying to find
out about mpm connect
okay so there we have uh two individuals
in there who say that they haven't heard
of Peter Hearn of npm connect uh and
shut the door when we ask more questions
no like being shed here just an
accountant's firm where hundreds of
companies have registered themselves
this all completely permitted under a
system that allows firms as well as
people to donate but makes answers hard
to reach all a question of transparency
and bigger than one company or one party
there are examples in this leaderboard
where the data alone presents us with a
straight up mystery here is the case of
IX Wireless why would 24 MPS all
Northern Tories each be handed between
two and nine thousand pounds from a
small little known Northern Broadband
company
why would they do it and who's behind it
a new beginning
a new dawn
a New Horizon glossy promotional videos
promise a network for everyone an IX
Wireless of one high profile support
from government then culture secretary
Oliver Dowden appearing next to founder
Tahir masan for the firmed Blackburn
launch it really is going to provide
some of the fastest Broadband speeds on
the planet to tens of thousands of
people across the northwest
[Applause]
not all locals were as impressed as the
government Minister many angry at the
sudden appearance of large polls put up
by IX Wireless in their neighborhoods
the company's website its accounts phone
calls to IX Wireless and its sister
company 6G internet based at the same
address offered few clues why the firm
should be donating in this way
we've had a bit of a brick wall because
they say it's company policy not to hand
the media the email address for the
Press office so we're just gonna have to
knock on the door
foreign
any company whatsoever the floor looks
pretty damp that there's really no sign
of life it doesn't look like there has
been for for some time
no answers so I called the number on
their website they immediately confirmed
this was the right address
I'm calling from Sky News my name's Sam
case I'm just trying to get in touch
with
um somebody from lights Wireless to
answer our questions I'm actually
standing outside Rebel house and there
doesn't seem to be anybody here
she sounded unsure
are you inside Ribble house she said
there will be and that she'd find
someone to answer my questions then put
me on hold
after a while I was told there was
nobody who could talk to me
there does anyone work in there no
answer she asked me for my details and
said someone would be in touch the call
never came
24 conservative MPS have accepted
donations from IX Wireless one has since
defected to the labor party Christian
wakeford described how he applied for
campaign cash to fellow MP and head of
the northern research group Jake Berry
when it arrived a month later they were
told to register it from IX Wireless
before you were told that the donation
had come from IX Wireless had you ever
heard of them I'd never heard of them no
literally the first time I'd ever heard
was that email saying this this is who
you need to uh to put against the
register for the donation
Jake Barry declined to answer what his
relationship was with the firm and its
founder to hear masan
the Westminster accounts project was
designed to show us who gives and help
us to understand why but in some cases
answering those questions is simply not
possible the current system does not
make it easy to follow the money and MPS
can choose to avoid the most basic
questions I think the basic Assumption
of most MPS is that if they're following
the rules that they've been told to
follow they've made their declarations
but I think there's a bigger question
here is that transparency actually
sufficient if an MP is asked for more
information should they feel that
actually that is something that they're
willing and able to give do they
actually know the answer to some of
these questions if they've taken money
from from a company that they don't
necessarily know how that is funded I
think that's actually quite important
MPS tell us the rules on donations give
us transparency but just following those
rules has left so many questions
unanswered an absence of information
the most important donations go to the
most important people who have the
biggest sway over our lives leaders past
and present under the spotlight tomorrow
as we continue to examine what's in the
Westminster accounts
[Music]